ever since 2019 Apple has been secretly
working on a massive push into the AAA
gaming industry and now four years later
they're about to reveal it at wwc on
June 5th and in this video I'm going to
show you a bunch of evidence for why
it's finally gonna happen the most
important news you need to know is that
hideo Kojima the creator of the famous
Metal Gear Solid franchise and many
other games has been spotted by Apple's
campus a week or so ago which means who
could be a part of WWDC and two days
before that tweet by Mark German an
Apple employee posted a photo of a path
that leads to the Steve Jobs theater
that said production in process do not
enter so just like every event in the
last couple of years apple is filming
the WWDC keynote video and hideo was
there as well so why would he be there
well the only reason is that Apple has
some major gaming related announcements
to make at WWDC and they wanted a
well-known face in the world of gaming
to show it off but going even deeper
hideo was interviewed last year in
October and he said that his next
project would change not only the video
gaming industry but also the film
industry irrevocably he said that he's
wanted to make whatever it is that comes
next for years but the technology was
insufficient to achieve his Ambitions
until now he said it's almost like a new
medium for gaming and if this exceeds it
will turn things around not just in the
game industry but in the movie industry
as well what that sounds like to me is a
new VR based game that's completely out
of this world incredible something that
wasn't possible until the creation of
Apple's VR headset which we already know
is coming at WWDC Mark German already
reported that Apple was planning some
interesting games and gaming related
features coming to the headset including
the ability to run most of Apple's
existing iPad apps in mixed reality
including games and having a gaming
focus with top tier titles from existing
third-party developers on top of that
polymer lucky the creator of the Oculus
headset said that the Apple headset is
so good which really says a lot however
there were many Apple Executives that
were recently worried about the headset
success due to the high price and
unfortunate Market timing in terms of
the economy so with apple moving forward
with the release of their headset I
believe that they've been preparing some
absolutely incredible games including
this massive industry changing potential
project from hideo Kojima way back in
2019 there were reports that Apple was
working with Studios to create AAA games
that were huge in scale similar to the
big Zelda games but we didn't hear much
about it ever since but everyone who
knows about AAA games know that they
take years to create so now that we're
in 2023 four years later I think apple
is finally ready to show them off to the
world back then we even had leaks from
other sources about Apple working on a
gaming console including a dedicated
gaming controller but none of that came
to light what if Apple has been holding
off until the release of the VR headset
to reveal all of this all at once in a
massive gaming push this user on Twitter
came up with an Apple gaming hypothesis
which includes Apple packing their
various devices like Macs iPads and the
VR headset with the same M2 to chip so
that the experience is consistent across
all of the platforms and it's easier for
the game developers to make the games
for them now that they're powerful
enough not only that but a game maker
would only need to create the game once
since all of these devices now run on
Apple silicon hardware and software
there would just need to be a little bit
of optimization done for each UI and
display size and that's it and
coincidentally epic's Unreal Engine just
got native Apple silicon Mac support
right before WWDC which could point to
that being a huge part of the gaming
push showing developers how to develop
games for the Apple devices now way back
in 2020 Apple's own developer videos
even talked about how to optimize games
for a cross-platform use so people can
play on any Apple device together but
going even deeper I got some very
interesting info from Hachi tech on
Twitter claiming that apple is planning
a new Apple TV or gaming console that'll
be released alongside a new M2 Max and
the VR headset with the focus on cross
platform gaming he even said that Apple
has been slowly restructuring the
company for a while now even creating
its own full-scale Apple games
development section or AAA Apple gaming
studio just like they did for Apple TV
plus he says that they're basically
going all in on gaming and the
integration of vros and the headset to
Mac OS iPad OS and iOS is just unreal
and if they get the stuff working right
it's going to be mind-blowing now to me
that sort of sounds like the new
game-changing medium hideo was talking
about and for Apple it makes sense to
partner up with him one user on Twitter
said that if Kojima is involved he's got
some amazing stuff cooking in VR people
are still waiting for some specific
remakes of metal gear so imagine Metal
Gear in VR on the Apple headset if he
announces that during WWDC The Gaming
Community will go Bonkers it would be a
sign that Apple has entered the big boy
scene and that is exactly what Apple
needs if they are to enter the gaming
industry with a huge push and it's
really the only way they can make their
VR headset succeed at least at first
with exclusive incredible games and
experiences that you can only get on
Apple's headset so that explains the
whole new Apple gaming studio as well as
a software integration with Apple's
other products to make the headset worth
the very high cost however we just got a
major leak showing that Apple's headset
might not be as expensive as we
previously thought which was around
three thousand dollars it was a leaked
bom or a bill of materials for the
headset which was translated on Twitter
apparently apple is going to position it
as a non-profit product so they won't
apply the same profit margins as they do
with their other devices at least not at
first there will be two chips costing
around 120 to 140 each a camera with 14
sensors a micro LED display and a bunch
of other parts totaling around 1400 or
including shipping in boxes and
everything else around sixteen hundred
dollars it could be that Apple ends up
selling it for 19.99 which might not
sound that bad when we actually get to
see all the specs and features at WWDC
especially if they truly are doing a
massive push into AAA gaming but now
here's my take and prediction on what's
gonna happen I fully believe that apple
is going to come out with a bang when
they unveil the VR headset telling
everyone that they now have a dedicated
gaming studio and they're going to
reveal a bunch of brand new game titles
and show off all of their trailers I
think Apple has wanted to get into AAA
gaming for a long time but they were
honestly waiting for the Apple silicon
architecture to make sure that these
games will run on all of their devices
with Incredible optimization this was
only possible when Apple ditched Intel
three years ago but it took that long
because these games needed to be built
for Apple silicon from scratch to ensure
that they would run well and show off
just how impressive their apple silicon
really is being able to run the same
games on every device even on the iPhone
I also believe that they're planning to
bring Hardware Ray tracing to the Next
Generation a17 and M3 family chips which
was already in the rumor cycle
especially the new GPU design that was
supposed to come to the a16 but was
delayed until the a17 but Mark German
has clearly said on Twitter that he
thinks Apple could end up giving the VR
headset a new chip with completely
different branding from the M2 Chip even
though the technology and specs might be
very similar but either way if you're
excited for Apple's WWDC event check out
that video for more leaked products
which could be coming and click that
Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
foreign